Alright, so I was thinking today about how
to explain this a little bit further.
So let’s say you’re going for a job interview.
And you’re nervous about it.
And you go into the job interview and there
are some people there, and some chairs and
tables, and a room that’s like this, maybe
not quite this ugly, but something like this.
What’s in the room?
You’re nervous.
You’ve seen chairs and tables before, you’ve
seen people.
What’s in the room?
How about a set of alternate futures?
Right?
You know, that isn’t how we think.
It’s how we act.
And you know, if you talk about it, I was
nervous about going to this job interview.
Why?
Well I thought I might be evaluated.
Okay, well why does that matter?
Well, we know partly why it matters if we
look at this figure again.
I’m pretty happy with this figure, all things
considered.
You know, and you might say, well if I…
maybe it’ll shape my faith and my belief
that I’m a good person.
That would be a little silly for an interview.
So if you’re thinking that way I would say
you’re not thinking specifically enough.
Because there’s lots of reasons you might
not do well at the job interview, including
the fact that they might have already given
the job to someone else, for all you know.
So you don’t want to leap to the top of
the hierarchy without cause.
So one of the things you might say is that
in the room there, there are threats that
might be posed to any level of the hierarchy
of beliefs and behaviours that you use to
interact with the world.
Now the terror management people would tell
you… let’s assume that this [points to
figure on board] is a belief structure.
I don’t care whether you agree with the
way it’s represented graphically or not,
for the time being, but let’s just assume
that what we’re talking about is a belief
structure.
Now the terror management people would tell
you that you have that belief structure, in
large part to protect you from the fear of
death, from death anxiety.
But there’s a bunch of problems with that
idea, not least that it actually side-steps
the issue of the function of the belief system.
It’s like, you don’t exactly have a belief
system to make philosophical sense out of
the world.
You have a system of tools, that are embodied,
that allow you to actually act in the world.
Now you might also have an articulated representation
of that on top that’s more or less accurate.
Probably less, all things considered.
And you know, maybe if your faith in that
is shaken, your faith in what you do will
also be shaken, because the two things are
associated.
But we should always remember that a belief
system doesn’t just protect you from the
fear of death, it protects you from death.
And that’s a lot different, you know.
I mean, this whole thing is your set of skills,
and the perceptions and thoughts and emotions
that go along with those skills, and then
it’s an integrated structure consisting
of the particular manner in which you’ve
integrated all your own little sub-parts and
then in relationship to the whole community.
You could also think about it, in some sense,
as a holographic representation of the culture.
Now, I don’t know how much you guys know
about holographs.
I don’t know very much about them either.
But there are some things I know about them…
so if you shine a light on a holograph, you’ll
get a 3D image of whatever was there when
the holograph was created; it’s created
by lasers.
And if you take a holograph and you break
it into pieces, and then you shine a light
on the pieces, you get the object in each
piece.
But it’s low resolution.
It’s a nice way of thinking about a person.
Like if your brain is damaged you’ll be
there, but as a lower resolution representation
of yourself.
But it’s also a really nice way of thinking
about what culture is.
You know, culture is this massive structure
of multiple levels and domains, but it’s
reflected in each of us.
Like, we’re each partial carriers of it.
So we embody a partial representation of the
structure.
I mean literally, we embody it.
And then we also represent it abstractly.
And you know, part of the reason that you
go to a university is to, in some sense, improve
your capacity to articulate your structure.
Right, because you’re a cultural creature…
it’s like, why are you the way you are?
Well, some of it is psychological, some of
it is sociological, some of it is historical.
Like a lot of it is historical.
So when you go and you study a social science
or a humanity, you’re studying your own
personality.
Now, I wrote a paper a while back with a couple
of my graduate students, and I think it was
called The Entropy…
God, you’d think I would remember this…
The Entropy… doesn’t matter.
The hypothesis was, and this is something
I’ve been think about for a long time, that
the world is very, very complex, and so what
that means is that the act of getting from
one place to another is often very, very difficult.
And part of what you’re doing when you put
together a functional sub-module is you’re
putting together a little routine that will
enable you to transform some part of time
and space from what it is into what you want
it to be.
And in some sense what you’re doing is reducing
the complexity of that situation.
So imagine this, you’re going for your job
interview.
And you’re knocking ‘em dead.
What happens?
Well, a whole bunch of possibilities, all
that set of possibilities that was concerning
you, starts to collapse towards a single solution.
And that single solution is, if you’re doing
very well in the interview, it’s a positive
solution.
So you’re anxiety disappears and it’s
replaced with positive emotion.
You get enthusiastic and excited, because
what’s happening in that room is that the
path to a desirable future is opening.
Now you can’t see any of this, you know,
because we’re so blinded by the idea that
we see objects…
we fail to perceive, in any articulated sense,
what it is that we’re actually dealing with.
And I think that one way of thinking about
it is that you’re always on the edge of
something that’s potential, and that’s
where you exist.
You exist on this moving boundary of potential.
And you can interact with it such that you
form it and it passes by you into the past.
And hopefully you’re forming it in a way
that is in concordance with your better health
and perhaps with the better health of the
people around you, that would be optimal.
So you’re realising the potential in a genuine,
non-metaphorical sense.
And that’s the thing about these representations,
you know.
They’re often described as mythical, or
mythological, or metaphorical.
But you know, they’re really not metaphorical.
Well, that’s not exactly right, because
the Great Mother, the Great Father, they’re
partially metaphorical but the thing that
they stand for as metaphors is something other
than the things that we conceptualise when
we look at the world from an objective perspective.
Now, we’ve talked a little bit about the
figure of the Dragon of Chaos, and I think
that out of all the metaphorical images, it’s
the most difficult to grasp, because it’s
that which has not yet been encountered, so
it’s neither unknown nor known.
And you think, well you can’t even describe
that.
Yeah, but you can encounter it, and you can
encounter it when you go into a situation
that’s radically new.
Let’s say it’s just the second before
you walk into a high-stakes interview, you
know, just before you open the door.
I would say that’s as close as you get,
in a normal day, to a direct encounter with
the dragon of chaos, because you don’t know
what’s going to happen.
And to say, well, you’re in a room and there’s
a door in front of you, you know it’s almost
moronic to think of it that way, right?
Because what the hell does that have to do
with anything?
It’s… what’s in there is unbelievably…
like it’s the localisation of unbelievably
complex webs of causality.
That’s what’s waiting for you inside that
room.
And then you might say, well is it structured
in any real way, and the answer to that is
not really.
It’s no more structured than… it’s even
less structured than a book you’re reading.
You know, if you’re reading a book you might
say, well where’s the meaning in this book?
And the answer to that is, well it’s not
in the book.
Like it’s partly there, because you need
the words and the sentences and the paragraphs
and all that, but you need the whole cultural
context around it in order to interpret it.
So you’re not reading it blank.
You come to it with a set of, a very large
set of presuppositions.
Enough of them so that you can understand
the author.
Now maybe you can’t, and the book’s over
your head, or it’s badly written, but typically,
you come at it with the machinery in place,
so that when you interact with the words and
the phrases and the sentences and so forth,
revelations of new meaning pour forth.
And so, I don’t know how to say it any clearer
than that, that’s what the meaning of the
book is.
And it’s in the dialectical interaction
between you and the book.
Well, if you walk into an interview room,
it’s even less given, in some sense, than
the book, right.
Because what’s going to happen in there,
which really means which of the many futures
that that room contains is going to manifest
itself, depends very much on how you act.
So, it’s in that way that you collapse the
potential that’s in a particular place and
you extract something out of it that’s…
well, and that’s when it gets tricky…
neutral, positive, or negative?
Maybe you bomb the interview, right?
And then you might say, well what’s happened?
What happened?
Well that’s a very complicated question.
Then you’re stuck with this hierarchy, right.
And that’s what you’re going to do when
you go home.
You’re going to say “well maybe I didn’t
dress properly, or maybe I didn’t get to
the interview on time, or they asked me a
bunch of questions I wasn’t prepared for,
or Jesus, I didn’t know anything about what’s
going on, my whole education was a waste of
time, and what the hell am I doing”?
And then you might go “I’m never going
to get a job”.
And you know, you could say in some sense
that all of those hypotheses, as you move
up and down the hierarchy, you move from trivial
trouble to really not good trouble, as you
bounce, and all of that is an attempt to specify,
in some sense, what that room contained.
And it’s not easy.
It’s weird too, because the room can contain
things that alter your past.
Because maybe you say, well maybe you’re
going for a computer science job, maybe you’re
not, whatever.
You go in there and you think you’re the
top person in your class, and maybe you were,
but you know the people in there are so far
ahead of you that you can’t even imagine
ever catching up.
And you know, when you come out of there,
the manner in which you construe your educational
history is going to be radically transformed.
So there’s a lot of trouble in that room.
There’s a lot.
Now one of the things we though in this paper…
you can think of each of those little eggs,
they’re really eggs, as a container, and
what they contain is entropy, trouble.
And the smaller ones contain smaller amounts
of entropy and the bigger ones contain bigger
amounts of entropy.
And so, here’s another example.
You’re driving down the highway and your
car sputters and grinds to a halt.
Maybe it makes a nice radical noise while
it’s doing it.
So okay, well, what happened?
Well the answer is, the simple answer is,
your car malfunctioned and you had to pull
off the road.
That’s a really object-oriented analysis.
But what’s actually happened is that you
had a conceptualisation of the car as a pragmatic
tool, because what do you know about the damn
car?
The car was an affordance, that’s the right
word, that would get you from point A to point
B, and you could have a very low-resolution
model of it, right?
It can just look like a plastic shell, which
is sort of what a car looks like.
And as long as you see how low-resolution
that is, you could replace it with a cartoon
and you wouldn’t even notice.
That’s good enough representation as long
as the thing is doing what it’s supposed
to be doing.
But as soon as it stops doing what it’s
supposed to be doing then it could be any
old thing.
And you think, well what does any old thing
mean?
Well maybe you’re on a deserted highway
and it’s one o’clock in the morning.
And you know, someone pulls over to help you.
Okay, well, what’s that?
Well, you know, believe me, your imagination
will rapidly span the world of possibility
from “oh good, someone’s come to help”
to “I’m going to be dragged off in the
bush and killed”.
And that’s all contained in that sequence
of events.
And then even if no one does stop, and you
have to worry about exactly what’s gone
wrong, and you have to worry about how you’re
going to fix it and you have to worry about
the mechanic that might help you, and you
have to concern yourself with whether or not
you’re going to need a new car, and then
you have to think about your finances.
It’s like, the idea that that car is a bounded
entity, like it looks, is only true when it
works.
And as soon as it doesn’t work, then God,
it’s any old thing.
And that, in some sense, is the dragon of
chaos.
Now, what seems to me to have happened…
because you might think, well how did people
come to conceptualise such a thing, because
I would think that, of all the things that
are difficult to conceptualise, the category
of all things that you have not yet encountered
is the most difficult thing to discover, right?
It’s kind of like zero.
It took people a long time to figure out zero,
and no wonder.
We need a symbol for nothing.
Well, this is even worse.
We need a representation for potential.
Well, you think, why?
Well it’s because it’s actually potential
that you’re interacting with all the time.
Now what seems to me to have happened was
that… you know, this is an evolutionary
just-so story, so I’m not assuming that
it worked precisely this way, but it doesn’t
matter.
Because I’m going to touch on the appropriate
features.
Well one of the things we know about social
animals, generally speaking, and animals in
general, is that they have a territory, right?
And so you think, well what is their territory
exactly?
And you might say, well you can mark it out.
Here’s a… oh, what would have a territory?
Like a tiger, they’re pretty solitary, so
it’ll be simple.
They have a big territory, right?
And it’s hundreds of square miles.
And the reason for that is, well they’re
tigers.
You can’t have like fifty of them, because
they’ll just eat everything that’s there.
You know, you have to have a big territory
to support one apex predator.
So then you might say, well what exactly is
the territory of the tiger?
And you’d say well here are its boundaries.
This is where it roams.
But that’s not the right way of thinking
about the territory of the tiger.
Because the territory of the tiger is actually
all the places where, when the tiger does
its thing, the things that the tiger wants
or expects, happen.
That’s the tiger’s territory.
It’s the same with you.
You’re at home wherever you know what to
do.
And what you’re doing when you know what
to do is you know how to match this hierarchy,
which is partly action-oriented, you know
how to match the hierarchy with the situation.
So that when you put it into practice, the
potential that’s there transforms itself
into what you’re aiming at.
And that’s your territory.
And you need to think about it that way because
your territory can shift very rapidly on you,
and if you think about it geographically,
it’s kind of confusing.
So let’s say you’re on the subway that
you always take.
And then someone sits down beside you and
they’re muttering away madly and they have
a pretty malevolent look on their face.
And you get a glimpse inside their coat and
there’s a knife.
It’s like, you’re not in your territory
anymore!
And the fact that all of the objective entities
are still there arrayed around you is just
a… it’s nothing more than a… it’s
a delusion at that point to think that those
things characterise where you are.
Okay so, if you’re willing to consider territory
as that…
it’s a space-time continuum, okay?
And the reason I’m stressing that…
I mean, first of all, whatever reality is,
is a space-time continuum, right?
It’s got three dimensions of space and one
dimension of time.
And everyone knows that, as we sit here, more
or less stable in three dimensions, time flows
past us, in some sense.
And so the three-dimensional reality is transforming
all by itself, just because of time.
Okay, and so when we’re mapping out our
territories, we map out space-time territories.
And so, that means that not only do you know
where you are, you know when you are.
And if you’re in your territory you know
how to act through that place and that time
so that you transform the potential that’s
there into whatever it is that you’re aiming
at.
Okay, so that’s your territory.
Now, that territory is isomorphic evolutionarily
with lots of things, which you could also
confuse geographically.
So you might think of a human territory as
something like… it’s probably, the fundamental
human territory is probably a fire.
And so the fire is a place of light in the
darkness and then you could think of rings,
concentric rings of relative safety surrounding
the fire.
So right beside the fire, where it’s warm
and light and there’s lots of other people,
man that’s explored territory, you know?
But then if you start wandering away from
the fire into the bush, especially if you’re
in a very biologically active area, then the
farther away you get from the fire the more
you’re going outside your territory.
And you can tell that’s happening because
your whole nervous system starts to function
differently.
What happens is that the nervous system parts
that you were using while you were in known
territory, they just shut down, and then other
nervous system elements that you used in unknown
territory start to turn on.
And generally you’re not very happy about
that.
Because when you’re aware you’ve mastered
the territory, you can presume that neutral
or moderately good things are going to happen,
with the possibility of something great now
and then.
But as you move away from that, it flips in
some sense to “I don’t know what’s going
on here and I might fall” to “something’s
going to bite me” to “I’m going to die
a painful death”, you know, and you don’t
use the same circuits to process the first
situation to process the first situation as
you do to process the second.
You don’t even like having the second one
on.
So you know what it’s like… maybe you’ve
been feeling a bit down, because that always
helps, and you wake up at three in the morning
and you’re worrying about six things and
you hear some random noise somewhere there
shouldn’t be a random noise.
Well, how you feel right then, that’s what
it is like to have the system that deals with
the unexpected ‘on’.
You’re like a prey animal.
Really, really, exactly like one, because
that’s what you actually are in many ways.
So you know, your whole biology transforms
so that you’re prepared for God only knows
what.
Well, what seemed to have happened in the
course of evolution was that, when we were
smaller creatures, and far after that, before
let’s say we figured out how to use throwing
sticks and slings, and then later maybe bows
and arrows, or maybe even sticks, like, we
were getting eaten a lot.
I think I told you guys last week that they
just discovered this damn cat in Africa that
looks like it preyed on our fore-bearers.
And we have pretty hard skulls so the normal
cat can’t really gnaw through them, but
this cat had a special set of teeth, and if
it grabbed the front of your head it would
drive one of its teeth right through the back
of your skull.
So you know, the hominids were preyed on enough
so that they had their own predators.
Well, so you know, that’s just not very
pleasant.
And then, that’s by the time we were hominids.
You can go back farther than that to when
we were little tree rats, roughly speaking,
and then all sorts of things were eating us.
There were a lot of reptiles back then, sixty
million years ago, and they weren’t pleasant.
There were still dinosaurs around sixty million
years ago.
You know, that’s a lot of evolutionary time
for us to have developed biological systems
that distinguish between places we’re safe
and places we’re not safe.
Well, you roughly have one set of neuropsychological,
neuropsychophysiological functions for familiar
territory and another set for unfamiliar territory.
Now what I would say… this is where this
becomes, I think, radically different to terror
management theory, what these hierarchy is
doing when it’s functioning is shutting
off… is keeping a system that operates in
unexplored territory shut off.
And you like that.
And that’s when you’re calm.
Like you are in here, you’re relatively
at home here, because you assume that you
know how to act here, as long as you sit and
ask questions more or less appropriately and
you don’t bother people and you don’t
talk on your phone, and various other things,
the probability that you’re going to confronted
by an angry primate or some other predator
is very, very low.
And so, you’d say, well you’re normal.
You feel like you do normally here.
But I would say the only reason you feel that
way normally to begin with is because you
don’t go places where you feel not normal.
You stay away from them.
And everyone knows what those places are like.
I saw a real cool example of this once.
I was down by OCAD at about midnight on a
Saturday night.
You know, it was in the summer so there were
all these kids, really, wandering around in
their party clothes and going to the clubs.
And I was standing there watching and I looked
through a park at this street that runs by
near OCAD and there were these houses.
There was a row of houses and there were three
houses here and they were all really nicely
taken care of, then there was a house here,
and then there were some more houses over
here that were well taken care of.
And that house in the middle was condemned.
So the roof was rotting and they’d boarded
up all the windows, and the fence was falling
off and there was garbage in the yard, it
was a derelict place, you know.
So that’s kind of a spooky place.
Well, while I was standing there this guy
walked down the street, and he was very intoxicated,
and he wasn’t very happy and he was sort
of muttering to himself.
And he passed the three houses that were in
pretty good shape, and then as soon as he
got in front of the house that was derelict,
he just started to rant, and he was pounding
up and down and muttering paranoid things,
and you know, sounding really dangerous.
But he kept more or less moving forward, and
then just after he got back past that borderline
and back into the more or less normal neighbourhood,
he switched back to just mumbling quietly
and kept moving forward.
And you know he was just so damn intoxicated,
there isn’t a possibility that he noticed
what had happened, but he was being cued by
the surroundings, you know, and it was a different
‘him’ when he was in unexplored territory,
something that had degenerated back into chaos.
So the anger and aggression came out of him
because that’s often necessary if you’re
going to be where there’s chaos.
You know, and chaos can burst forth, and does,
all the time in people’s lives, you know.
If you’re sitting around the dinner table
with your family, and everything’s going
pretty well but someone touches on one of
those topics that you should just shut the
hell up about, it can take almost no time
at all before the whole thing unravels, and
then God only knows where you are.
And it’s not pleasant.
So instead of our belief systems protecting
us from death anxiety, our hierarchical pragmatic
systems for interacting with the world stop
the parts of our brain that deal with the
unexpected from being on.
And they don’t do that because we believe,
they do that because when we enact those structures,
all hell doesn’t break loose.
So there’s nothing illusory about it.
Now, you know, you might say, well, in the
final analysis, does it really protect you
from chaos?
And you know, that’s an okay question, but
most of the time that’s irrelevant.
It isn’t always irrelevant, but most of
the time it just doesn’t matter.
And the other thing is that much of the time
it doesn’t even matter if you believe this.
By which I would mean, you have an articulated
representation of it, it’s also a self-representation,
and you carry that around, and maybe you have
a crisis of faith and you don’t believe
in that, you still act all this stuff out.
And most of the time you’re still extremely
well-protected by it.
So it’s more robust than merely the articulated
or imagined version.
It’s a lot deeper than that.
It’s only a tiny part of its structure.
And so, we should never really talk about
‘belief systems’ exactly, especially not
if they’re shared with very many other people,
because they’re not structures of belief,
they’re much deeper structures than that.
And the belief part is only a pale reflection
of the underlying reality.
Okay, so that…
I presume that makes sense, and you can make
sense of that in your own life.
You know, there’s other things that can
happen too that I should mention, is lots
of times people have chaos… you know, you
think your body is explored territory, it’s
sort of the ultimate explored territory.
But I would say, don’t get too convinced
about that.
That can also switch in a moment, and it happens
to people all the time.
So if you get a tooth pulled, it takes your
tongue like three months to map the inside
of your mouth again.
So that’s re-familiarising your brain with
the new territory, right?
And that’s very, very complicated.
So your body representation is extremely complicated.
And it’s really easy to screw up.
So if you have someone go like that [crosses
forearms and hands and fingers] and then you
point to one of their fingers in the middle
and get them to move it (don’t touch it),
they often can’t, because just that’s
enough to boggle up their visual representation
of their body.
And so you can play all sorts of tricks on
people that way.
So you know, your map of your body and your
body are sort of reasonably well associated,
but they can be dissociated quite rapidly,
and you know that happens when, maybe you
get a little hypochondriacal and start worrying
about your health.
Something’s bugging you and you don’t
exactly know what it is.
It’s like, well, all of a sudden you get
alienated from your body.
And that can get really serious.
And I’ve seen people after a car accident,
this was the most striking of this, this client
I had had her shoulder up like this [stiffens
right shoulder].
And I noticed she never really looked in the
direction of that arm and when she moved it
she’d only move it about this far.
And after seeing her for a while I thought
“oh, she’s afraid of that arm”.
Now it had been hurt.
Well why would you get afraid of your arm?
Well, it doesn’t act like it used to, so
that’s annoying.
And then when you move it wrong it hurts,
and then you also don’t know that if you
move it wrong and it hurts, whether you’re
making it worse.
So then you just kind of ignore it, and then
it’s sort of your arm and sort of not your
arm.
And I had her at one point, we just practiced
just doing this [loosens shoulder].
I’d say, I’d do the action and say “can
you do this?”
[Raises left arm slightly].
She’d do it.
And then I’d go “well can you do this?”
[Raises arm slightly higher].
And she’d do it.
And then I’d say “can you do this?”
[Raises arm even higher].
We just kept doing this, it only took about
half an hour until she was up here [arm fully
raised], and she said “I haven’t put my
arm up there for two years!”
And then I did the same thing with her shoulder.
I said, “Can you lift your shoulder?”
“No.”
“Can you lift it one-sixteenth of an inch?”
Well, she could do that.
Well, you know, sixteen times one-sixteenth
of an inch is an inch, and that’s starting
to get there.
And you know, she did this a bunch and then
her arm went down.
So she’d been holding the damn arm up for
two years.
Just try that.
You know, I mean you do this [raises arm]
for five minutes and see what happens, just
hold your shoulder up there for two years
and see what that does to the entire right
side of your body.
Like it’s really, really stressful.
And then I did something strange, then, which
was a whim, but I think it was because I was
embodying her because I was paying so close
attention.
I asked her to come lean over my desk because
there was something about the way she was
holding herself that was really bugging me.
And so I asked her just to lean over my desk
and I pounded on her back down her spinal
cord and she drooped her shoulders again and
then she cried for about half an hour.
And again, it was because, she’d got hit
by a car, that’s just how she was, she just
walked around like that, permanently, more
or less.
And we worked it out of her reasonably well.
But even your own damn body can become unexplored
territory.
And that’s another way of understanding
that yin-yang symbol, right?
You’ve got the black serpent, paisley, and
it’s got a little white dot in it.
Which means that sometimes when things are
really broken all to hell a solution can come
blasting forth and chaos turns into order.
But more likely, you know, everything’s
going pretty nicely and up something comes
and the chaos spills into the order.
And that’s the world you live in.
And that’s not a metaphor.
And it’s really interesting to know that,
because then the question becomes “okay,
well, what do you do in order and what do
you do in chaos?’
Those are useful things to know.
We kind of know what to do in order because
that sort of defines order.
But we don’t really know what to do in chaos,
you know.
In fact the field of mental health is in some
sense an attempt to figure that out.
But I can tell you some things to do when
you’re in chaos.
So let’s say you’re dealing with someone
who’s very, very ill.
Or maybe it’s you that’s very, very ill.
And so God only knows what’s going to happen
in the future.
Or even next week.
Well, the first thing you do is stop thinking
about next week and the future.
Because it’s not calculable, right?
The pathways have become so multiple and so
uncontrollable that if you think about them
it’s just going to hurt you.
And so, you know, you can’t just not think
about it, because that doesn’t work.
But what you can do is narrow your time-frame
of analysis.
You know, so instead of worrying about the
week, you think okay, well let’s make this
day as good as it can be.
And then if you’re really stressed, it’s
like, no we’re going to really work on this
hour.
And so what happens is you hyper-attend to
the local space-time area and that’s what
you’ve got.
You can work with that.
And it really works.
Like if you’re dealing with people who are
dying, for example, that’s what you do.
You zero in to the right level of resolution,
fundamentally.
And you can tell when it’s the right level
of resolution because you don’t feel like
you don’t know what you’re doing anymore.
“What am I doing here, what am I supposed
to do here, what does all this mean?”
You don’t feel that anymore.
Because those are the wrong questions at that
point in time.
And you know, maybe you try to make the person
comfortable, and you pay attention, so you
can take the right micro-movements and the
right micro-attitudes in those critical moments,
and that’s what you do.
And so that’s one way of dealing with the
underworld and you need to know that, because
it’s going to happen.
So if you’re really stressed, you think
about smaller amounts of space and time.
And you try to get them right, it’s still
important to get it right, but the entropy
is so high at that point, the landscape is
so complicated, that there’s no that you
can map more than a few moments at a time.
But it turns out often that that’s okay.
That’s good enough.
You know, obviously it’s not optimal, but
one thing you can be sure of is you can take
a terrible situation and you can make it a
hell of a lot worse.
So you know, if it’s a terrible situation
and you manage it as well as it can be managed,
then maybe it’s only terrible.
But if you take a terrible situation and you
manage it really badly, then it can be something
that you never, ever recover from.
So, I’m not trying to be hyper-optimistic
about this, I know people go through rough
times.
But there’s a difference between tragedy
and hell.
And tragedy is when something happens and
you’re awake.
And hell is when something terrible happens
and you’re not awake.
And that’s a place you really don’t want
to go.
So then the death of your father could turn
into the obliteration of your entire family.
Well, you know, the first is bad enough, but
the second might well be unbearable.
You know, because people often fight in circumstances
like that, and the family gets very, very
stressed.
It’s very common, for example, if a couple
has a sick child or a child that dies that
they get divorced.
It’s not surprising, you know.
It’s not like they have a psychological
problem, they have a real problem.
And they might be amplifying it with their
psychological problems, but all problems are
not psychological.
And that’s also useful to know, because
if you end up somewhere that you don’t expect,
you’re going to be thinking (especially
if you’re conscientious): “If I wasn’t
such a useless fool, I would have never ended
up here”.
And there’s a much more pessimistic thought
than that that’s much more useful, which
is: whether you were a fool or not you were
going to end up somewhere like this now and
then.
And you might think, God, that’s a horrible
thing to think, because that means that our
destinies are uncontrollable, at least in
part.
It’s like, yeah they are.
So partly what that means is prepare yourself
for that, and don’t pound yourself into
the ground when you get there.
Because it happens to people, and it isn’t
necessarily the case that the reason it happened
to you is because you’re useless.
Now, that might have furthered the process
and all that, but you just don’t need those
thoughts at that time.
All they do is undermine you.
And when you know “yeah, you know, everybody’s
dog dies” (which is true), it’s like,
well, it takes some of the guilt out of it,
and the guilt is something that at that point
you don’t really need.
Okay, so, you’ve got your explored territory,
and we’ve kind of walked through what that
is, and then you have your unexplored territory.
And then you have the things that sort of
exist on the fringe.
I would say in some sense the things that
exist on the fringe closer to the unknown,
those are usually symbolised by the Terrible
Mother.
And then the order is symbolised by the Terrible
Father.
And then the chaos that’s beyond order…
the unknown that’s beyond order and chaos,
that’s the Dragon of Chaos.
Now it’s a reptile, right, a reptilian carnivore.
It’s a reptilian carnivore that has a variety
of interesting properties.
So let me show you some of the pictures that
I’ve got of the dragon of chaos.
This is a good one.
So that’s a figure called an ‘Ouroboros’,
and you can say in some sense that that’s
one of the first graphical representations
of the infinite.
You know, we have a symbol for infinity, right,
which is another thing that’s pretty weird
to symbolise, because you’re encapsulating
something that can’t be encapsulated inside
a capsule, right.
It’s very sneaky to be able to do that.
And you actually need it to do advanced mathematics
of all sorts of kinds.
So it’s real, at least insofar as you can
use it as a tool.
So let me tell you a few things about this
symbol, this representation.
It’s kind of like the Judeo-Christian idea
of God being the Alpha and Omega.
Which is this thing that exists from the beginning
of time all the way to the end of time.
So it’s something that exists outside of
time.
So you could think about this, at one level,
as the eternal presence of The Predator.
Predators come and go; The Predator never
goes away.
So it’s got this God-like… you could say
the spirit of The Predator never disappears.
And as soon as you think that way then you
have some idea about what archaic people were
doing when they were populating the world
with spirits.
The difference between a spirit and an abstract
idea is like, there’s no difference.
The spirit of The Predator inhabits the jungle.
It’s like, yeah, that’s for sure.
And you should be very careful of disturbing
such spirits when you go in there.
Well so then you might ask yourself, well,
what is a predator?
Well, that’s a complicated thing, because
we would say, because we’re scientifically-minded,
that you can take predators and you can classify
according to their species and their sub-species
and their phyla and all that sort of thing,
right.
We think about classifying them as objects,
and then maybe in terms of their evolutionary
origins.
But that’s not very helpful.
You know, if something jumps out and wants
to eat you, I mean, knowing what it is might
help you plot your escape but all those additional
complexities, they’re just not the relevant
issue at that point.
The relevant issue is, how do you keep the
predators away from your explored territory?
Well, now that’s a complicated question,
because you might say: what do you mean by
that?
Do you mean right now, while you’re walking
through the bush?
Do you mean right now for you and your family,
while all of you are walking through the bush?
There’s this old joke about these two guys
that go out in the forest, and one guy says
to the other: “There’s grizzly bears here,
so you have to be careful.”
And then the other guy says, “Well, how
fast can you run?”
And the first guy says “Well, don’t you
mean how fast does the grizzly bear run?”
And the other guy says “No that isn’t
what I mean I just want to know if I can run
faster than you.”
[Laughter].
Right, right.
So the reason I’m telling you that stupid
joke is because what you want as an answer
to a question depends on exactly how you put
the question.
And so, the answer there was “well I don’t
care if the grizzly bear eats someone as long
as it’s not me.”
Okay, fine, so that’s one answer to the
question.
But then you might think, well let’s keep
the grizzly bears away from me now, my family
now, my tribe now, me tomorrow, my family
tomorrow, my tribe tomorrow, then across the
week, then across the month, then across the
years, then maybe forever.
Okay so how is it that you have to act so
that you keep the predators away?
Well, that starts to become an extraordinarily
complicated problem.
Because the simple solution might be, well
when there’s a predator around, climb a
tree or run into a hole, which is what lots
of animals do.
But it’s a pretty partial solution.
They don’t get eaten that day, but what
about tomorrow, when the predator’s a little
hungrier.
It’s kind of a bone-headed solution, all
things considered.
So then you might say, well, if we thought
of the spirit of the predator, which is more
like the fact that there is a class of predators
and they’re never going to go away, then
the question that we have to answer is, how
do we act so that that class that’s eternal
doesn’t bother us any more than necessary?
Well that’s really complicated.
Really, really complicated.
Because it might mean, in some sense, well,
how should you act?
Because conquering the problem of having your
territory invaded, there’s not just reptilian
and mammalian predators, right, like bird-things
with teeth, there’s other people.
And they’re a lot worse than anything else
that’s going to come at you, so you also
have that problem, how do you keep yourself
away from the predatory people and the foreign
tribes that are going to invade your land
and take it.
So there’s no difference between that question
and how do you establish the security of a
nation, roughly speaking.
Or maybe even how do you establish peace?
You know what I mean?
It’s a question that doesn’t have obvious
borders.
Okay, so one answer might be, stay away from
the damn predators.
So you build a big wall, or someone else does,
and you hide inside the walls.
Well, that’s not a bad solution, and of
course, that’s what people started to do
when they originally built cities, right?
They built these big walls, like Trump is
going to build between Canada and the US,
and it’ll keep the predators out.
But of course, what do we know from the story
of Genesis, and from the Daoist symbol?
No matter how big the wall is, you can’t
keep out the damn snakes.
So you build a wall and all the snakes pop
up inside, so it’s not a very good solution.
And you know, that’s pretty obvious, right?
I mean, my suspicions are that mass shooters
who are native to the United States kill a
lot more people in the US every week than
illegal Mexican immigrants.
Well, so it’s like, what problem exactly
are you solving?
Okay, so the first question you have to solve
when you’re… see there’s just no solution
to this problem [open doors in the classroom?][Laughter].
So, why did you laugh at that, do you think?
[Student: Because it opened again and it was
unexpected?]
Yeah, but why didn’t that terrify you?
Well, you know, it’s related to the hierarchy
issue, right?
Because the door isn’t behaving properly.
So what’s funny about that?
Well, it’s funny to watch someone’s little
routine not work when the consequences are
trivial.
It’s like, oh well he knows how to close
the door.
Hahaha it’s not working.
So now he’s got the problem of this door
and that’s a stupid problem, so everyone
can laugh about it, you know?
So, little anomalies, that you can bind quickly,
are common.
And I think it’s an indication, to tell
you the truth, I think it’s an indication
of people’s transcendent ability.
Because what happens, comedians do this with
you too, you know.
So you’ll be sitting in the audience, and
the comedian will say this thing and then
this thing, and they’re connected in some
way, but it’s not obvious.
And then you go, click!
And it’s like everybody celebrates their
brilliance together, like “Oh I get it!
Hahaha!
Aren’t I smart?”
And it transforms you from the puzzled thing
into the solving thing.
And everyone really likes that.
It’s like, “Yes!
We solved it.
We can go and combat the unknown together.”
Okay, so you have this chaos thing here [points
to figure].
As I said, that’s called an Ouroboros.
The reason it’s got its tail in its mouth
is… it’s a… the idea that that’s trying
to represent is that this thing is complete
unto itself.
So it’s a symbol of totality.
It’s everything.
How?
Well, you walk into the room where your interview
is.
You might say, what’s in there?
Well a better question is, what’s not in
there?
That’s a better question, because your whole
damn future’s in there.
And you don’t even know how much that branches.
Your future’s in there.
The future of your children is in there.
The future of your grandchildren is in there.
There’s these waves that go out from that
room that in some sense, especially if you
stretch them forward in time, have almost
no boundary.
You know, I mean, I don’t know, each of
us is descended from one person.
I don’t remember how many millions of years
ago, but it’s not that many.
Two?
Maybe it’s even earlier than that.
650,000 years?
Something like that.
So for all you know, one of you could be the
person through whom the entire human race
lived, and maybe it’s because you made the
right decision in that interview.
My point is that potential itself has no boundary,
no obvious boundary.
And you don’t know what you’re messing
with when you’re messing with it.
It’s very, very complicated.
So how should you do it?
Well, this figure says, well you better watch
out, because some of it is predatory, and
it crawls along the ground, and it’s got
teeth, and it’s no damn joke.
And then you can think it’s sort of snake-like,
because snakes sneak around through the grass.
And then it’s sort of crocodile-like, because
snakes don’t have teeth but crocodiles sure
the hell do, and so do other predatory lizards.
And you know, as we’ve talked about before,
the probability that our ancestral plains-dwelling
African ancestors were regularly lunched upon
by crocodiles is pretty damn high.
Because how else would they get water?
And you’ve got to be pretty mean before
you can take on a Nile crocodile.
I mean, I’m sure we did that fairly early
in our evolutionary history, but before that
a lot of us were snacks for lizards.
Which seems…
just not good, you know?
So this thing also lives in a hole, dragons
usually live in holes or underground, like
Harry Potter’s basilisk.
And usually they’re immortal.
They live in a cave, they’re immortal, right?
They live forever, and you don’t want to
bother them, because then they pop out of
their hole, like they do in The Hobbit, and
they come and burn down your village.
It’s like, leave the damn dragon alone.
Well, yes and no.
Why not leave it alone?
Well, maybe it would be better to go get the
dragon before it gets you.
That’s certainly possible.
And then there’s this other weird thing
about dragons which is that they hoard treasure.
So maybe you can go and confront the dragon
and you get the treasure.
And the treasure basically takes two forms.
So there’s the St. George story, where the
treasure is often a trapped, young female.
And the other version is the dragon sits on
gold.
So what’s the whole idea there?
Well, maybe the best way to overcome the predator,
the spirit of the predator, is to confront
it.
Well, that’s a hell of an idea.
Then you might think, well how deep an idea
is that?
You confront the predator, you get the gold.
Well, this is that you confront infinite possibility
and you get the reward.
You encounter infinite possibility properly.
You derive from it the rewards that it offers.
What are the rewards that infinite possibility
offers?
Who knows?
We have no idea.
And it’s so interesting, because we live
at a time in history where that’s literally
true.
Like I would hesitate to predict anything
about fifty years from now.
I quit worrying about the future about twenty
years ago.
Because I thought, oh, I get it.
No matter what happens, the probability that
it’s something I predict is zero.
So it’s like, whatever you’re worried
about, well, go ahead and worry about it,
but something completely different is going
to happen.
So it’s not really all that useful.
You should just be ready for whatever comes,
because here it comes.
You know, like I think we’ll have fully-functional
autonomous robots within three or four years.
And that’s a real game-changer.
And God only knows what’s going to happen
after that.
Transplantable organs… those things are…
you can print those on 3D printers already.
Well, augmented intelligence.
You all have augmented intelligence already.
What good are facts?
You just look them up, right?
Everyone’s an infinite supply of facts.
[Student: Can you explain, in different words,
why the dragon is eating its own tail?]
Because it has everything it needs.
That’s another way of thinking about it.
So it’s self-contained.
It doesn’t need anything outside of itself,
and there isn’t anything outside of itself.
So it doesn’t rely on anything to exist.
That’s another way of thinking about it.
It’s just there.
And so there’s an echo there of the idea
that… of an idea of beyond time.
Or I don’t know so much beyond space, but
certainly beyond time.
Time has no effect on it.
So it’s beyond time, in that sense.
Yeah?
[Student: There’s another reason it has
its tail in its mouth.
And that’s because it represents the border
between the known world, in all its goodness
and badness, and the unknown world.
And that border can get smaller as it eats
more of its tail.]
Mhm, right, right.
Okay, so, now it has wings, why does it have
wings?
Well, this is another horribly complicated
thing.
I’ll show you a diagram.
This is the closest I’ve been able to get
to it.
I often don’t talk about this diagram, but
I guess I am today.
Yeah, okay, we might as well go through this
completely.
Okay so here’s you.
So if you look right in the middle there,
here I’ll make it bigger so that you can
see it.
You kind of think that you’re right here.
This is where your consciousness normally
sits.
Like, you know, are you yourself, that’s
sort of your conscious body envelope and all
that, or are you your family?
Well you know, the border there is rather
pliable.
Well then, you can drill down into the cell,
and this is sort of the idea of hierarchy.
You know, you can look at principles, so those
are your general philosophical beliefs and
then your programs, and the sequence of behaviours
that you instantiate that in and then your
behaviours.
And then you can go below that even and you
can think of yourself as…
well because when you’re behaving, what’s
under that?
What’s the support for that?
The platform for that?
Well it’s your body, right?
Well, what’s there?
Well, once you get past the level of arm,
it’s sort of like musculature.
And then you might say, what’s under that,
what’s next?
Well you have your cellular structure, and
so that’s what cellular biologists study,
God that’s so complex.
And then below that you have your molecular
structures, like DNA, and then underneath
that there’s the atomic structure.
And then underneath that there’s the sub-atomic
structure, and what are you going to say about
that?
There isn’t even time at that level.
And then you can do the same thing if you
go up.
It’s like, people say you shouldn’t just
pay attention to your family, you’re in
a cultural group, they’re important too.
And well, what about the biological group
that that’s nested in, and maybe you should
be paying more attention to the ecosystem
rather than to yourself.
And you know, you shade upward into this thing
that you can’t really dissociate yourself
from either.
So that’s what you are, make no mistake
about it.
Your consciousness is such that you only are
located, in some sense, at one level of observation,
and God only knows why that is.
It’s almost as if being has to come to a
pinpoint in order for things to exist.
The way I’ve been thinking about it, in
some sense, is you could take all of this
structure and you know, narrow it down to
a single point of a pencil that’s writing.
And the writing is the transformation of potential
into actuality, but in order to do that there
has to be a point of contact between you and
the potential, and that’s your body in part,
but it’s even narrower than that.
It’s whatever occupies this tiny little
laser beam of attention while you’re wandering
through the world.
And it’s like burning reality into being.
So why that is, I mean, God, who knows?
It’s beyond strange.
Now, you know, one way of thinking about this
whole structure is you could think about it
as the psychological world, because you’re
at the centre of it, or you could think about
it as the spiritual world if you think about
spirit as a matter of consciousness.
It’s not the material world anyways, or
if it is it’s the material world insofar
as it’s you as a living conscious being.
So you know, we tend to separate out consciousness
and matter, right?
I mean, I’m conscious, that’s something
weird.
We don’t think this table is so we think
of them as separate substances in a sense,
spirit and matter.
Well that’s what the dragon is: it’s half
matter, that’s the thing that’s crawling
around on the ground, and it’s half spirit,
and that’s the wings.
And then you might say, well why the hell
is the dragon half spirit and half matter?
Well we’ve got the spirit part, I just showed
you it.
So now I’m going to show you the matter
part.
Okay, so we could say, well what’s that?
Well it’s a chair.
You think, that’s pretty straightforward.
It’s actually not, and I can tell you why
pretty rapidly.
Why is it a chair?
[Student: The legs?]
How about a beanbag?
Is that a chair?
That’s right because we can sit in it!
And that seems to be the fundamental issue:
is this a chair?
Is this a chair?
[Points to desk]
[Student: It can be.]
It can be, yeah, yeah.
You’d say it’s not a canonical chair,
and neither is a beanbag.
Because a chair could be a beanbag or a stump.
But you know, that’s sort of a canonical
chair.
But part of my point is, you know, the typical
answer that people will give when you ask
“why is that a chair?” is that they’ll
lay out the objective structure, that’s
only a tiny bit of a chair.
You know, if it was that high, would it be
a chair?
It has to have the right structure and the
right function in order for it to be a chair.
And so what that means is that thing which
is an object is already only existing in relationship
to you, in some important sense.
But I could also say well, it’s part of
the classroom.
What’s the classroom part of?
Well it’s part of Sid Smith.
This chair is part of Sid Smith.
And what’s Sid Smith part of?
Well it’s part of the university.
And what’s the university part of?
Well God, it’s part of all sorts of things,
but we could say it’s a piece of the city,
it’s a chunk of the province, it’s a bit
of the country, and then it’s nested inside
a much broader civilisation than that.
So that’s sort of going up from the chair.
And you could say, well, that’s not really
a chair, and I could say, well if that thing
was floating at some point halfway between
the Sun and Pluto, I don’t think considering
it a chair would be reasonable.
Because, well for obvious reasons.
You know, you can decontextualize something
so completely that it isn’t what it is anymore.
It’s not that hard.
You know, and you kind of do that to yourself
when you say, well, who cares, why is this
important?
Who’s going to know in a million years?
Poof!
You’re decontextualized.
It’s a stupid trick, it’s like a party
trick for intellects.
It’s a stupid trick, you know?
Because anybody can do it?
And what does it mean?
It means you’re looking at it from the wrong
perspective, that’s what it means.
So it’s not like it’s an ‘ultimate question’.
You wouldn’t be able to think about it in
fifteen seconds if it was an ultimate question.
But then you could do the same thing with
the chair that you did that you did with yourself
when you zoom in to it, right?
So it’s made of parts, well obviously, and
then the parts are made out of sub-parts and
so forth, all the way down to the sub-atomic
level.
And the chair is all those things at the same
time.
Okay, so then you might say, well what do
you encounter when you encounter the unknown?
And that’s what you encounter, I think.
So let’s take a look at this.
And you can think about it.
It’s a weird idea.
Okay, so you’ve got your little frame of
reference, right?
You’re going from point A to point B. And
when you’re going from point A to point
B something that you didn’t want to happen
happens.
And we already know that it can be a little
thing that happens, and then you know, haha
it’s funny, or it can be your whole world
falls apart, and then it’s a catastrophe.
But let’s say it’s something like the
interview.
So I would say that’s sort of a mid-level
anomaly, right?
You walk in, there’s a lot in there, but
you can handle it, weirdly enough.
And I suppose that’s because there are other
places that you can go where there are potential
futures lying, so it’s not like you’re
out of potential futures just because you
walk through that.
So you say, well, what’s in that room is
anomalous, you don’t understand it.
It’s unformed matter.
Now you might say, someone might say, does
this interview matter to you?
You think, that’s a pretty weird question,
because things are made out of matter.
So what do you mean when you say does this
matter to you?
Well, partly what it means is that before
matter was our matter, it was a matter that
was more complicated, linguistically speaking.
So if you go back far enough, what people
meant by matter wasn’t this [raps on desk].
It was more like, I would say, it’s more
like potential.
Or it’s more like information.
That’s another way of thinking about it.
So you could certainly say that room is chock-full
of information.
So let’s go with the information idea, just
for the sake of argument.
We already talked about it as potential, let’s
talk about it as information, both of those
work.
You walk in there and you start interacting
with people.
And then you leave later and you know, you
tell your partner “Well I went for this
interview.”
And they say “How did it go?”
And you say “Well, it didn’t go very well
but I learned some things.”
Because you could say that, right?
Well so I would say you went into that room
and you extracted some spirit out of the potential.
Now that’s exactly how Piaget looked at
it by the way.
Well, I shouldn’t say ‘exactly’ because
it’s probably not exactly the way he looked
at it.
But basically what Piaget proclaimed with
children was that children will try out a
little routine, and then something will happen
that doesn’t fit in their little routine.
And so they’ll investigate it using whatever
tools they have at hand.
Some of it’s trial and error, and some of
it’s… you know, they try out other tool-like
embodiments of their body that have worked
in the past.
So for example, the first thing a nine-month
old will do crawling around on the floor if
it encounters something that’s roughly mouth-sized
is put it in their mouth.
Why?
Well they don’t know what it is, but they
kind of know how to use their mouth.
So they throw it into their mouth, and then
they tongue it, and they get some sense of
sort of how it tastes, which is very important,
and what its shape is and all that, because
they’re very wired up in their mouth, and
so they can investigate like mad.
And so what they encounter is a thing and
then when they throw it in their mouth they
practice doing something with it, you know,
getting its shape, so now they know something
about it.
So that changes them from a spiritual perspective,
a psychological perspective.
Now they’re slightly different than they
were, they’ve incorporated some information,
and they’ve also transformed the thing into
a specific thing with specific features.
And so what you might say is that out of potential
spirit and matter arise.
And that’s a very interesting way of looking
at it.
Also it fits well with the phenomenological
philosophers.
Because they believe that we encountered phenomena
and phenomena were those things that shone
forth.
And so that’s like a reversion to the idea
of meaning.
Because you’ve got to think about it this
way too…
it’s like when you walk into a library,
God, what’s in there?
Well, it’s inexhaustible, a library.
Well, how come you just don’t get exhausted?
Well, it’s because you’re not actually
interacting with the whole library.
You’ve got this focal point like a laser
again, and you’ve made it into a focal point
because you’re inside that hierarchical
structure, right?
So you say, well I’m in the library to get
this book, I’m getting this book to read
this chapter.
So chapter, book, library.
I’m going to university, I need to become
educated and get a job so I’ll be a good
citizen and a good person.
And so that’s what you’re doing in the
library.
You’re just doing one little fragment of
that.
And the more you have that whole model developed,
right, all the way from good person all the
way down to why you’re in the library, the
more precise your aim is, the more you know
what you’re doing, the less encumbered by
doubt and uncertainty you are, and the higher
probability you have of focusing on your task
and then writing the path that you want to
be into being.
And so, well, so it’s very useful to think
about things this way and it’s also very
interesting to note that that’s how you
act.
You actually act like the world is made this
way.
And it’s even weirder because, and this
is the case I made for you when we were talking
about the structure of the brain.
It actually looks like this is how your brain
construes the world.
Because you have systems, you’ve got a system
that works when you know what you’re doing
and you’ve got the other system that works
when you don’t know what you’re doing.
And so basically the world is divided, just
like the Daoists say, into the orderly domain
and the chaotic domain.
And you need to know how to operate in both,
and you need to balance them.
And you need to transform one into the other.
And that’s basically what you’re doing
when you’re interacting with reality.
And you know, one of the things that I will
claim, and this will become more important
as the course progresses, is that when you’re
doing something meaningful, you’re doing
that properly.
And the sense of meaning that you have, is
actually an indication that your psychophysiology
is manifesting that you’re in the right
place at the right time doing the right thing.
And it’s real.
It’s not only real, it’s like it’s the
most real thing.
It’s where potential is transformed into
reality.
And it’s hard to get any more real than
that.
So that’s partly why I’m telling you that
these things aren’t exactly metaphors, you
know.
They have to be represented by metaphor in
some sense.
But the reality that’s underlying them…
it’s not just a story.
Even though it is a story, it’s not just
a story.
It’s a real representation of reality.
So, you know, the other thing I kind of outlined
here is that when you hit an anomaly… you
know an anomaly is sort of the thing from
which everything shines forth, when it’s
still really anomalous what happens is that
it manifests itself to you in sort of like
a burst of contradictory meanings.
And that can be paralysing.
You know, you could be really, really, really
excited and really, really, really nervous.
Which might happen, for example, if you were
going to a job interview and you actually
wanted the job.
It would be even worse if you went to a job
interview and like 30% of you wanted the job
because that’s the 30% of you that wants
to develop, and another 30% would just as
soon fail so that you can crawl under your
bed at home and stay there with the dust bunnies
until you’re forty.
And another 25% of you is resentful about
the fact that you have to get a stupid job
at all.
And so then you go in there and it’s really,
really complicated.
Because not only is all that potential there
but you’re fractured and those fractures
make the whole situation way more complicated
and unstable than it would otherwise have
to be.
And that happens to people all the time.
I mean, people hedge their bets in job interviews
all the time.
Because they think “eh, I don’t really
care.”
It’s like no, you care.
You just want to have a story to tell yourself
if you fail.
Well, and then if you have that story, well
then probably you’re going to fail, because
you don’t get to do that.
You can’t go in there at 60% and hope to
win.
You have to go in there at 100%.
Now that’s cool too, because what it implies
is just what the clinical psychologists have
been telling people for sixty years or seventy
years.
You have to voluntarily face the things that
you’re afraid of.
Now it’s a little more complicated than
that because otherwise you could just go play
in traffic.
So it’s not a call to stupid adventure.
What it does is assume that you’ve got a
direction and the direction is a valid direction.
And then what happens is, as you pursue that,
obstacles emerge, anomalous, threatening obstacles,
and then you either confront them, or you
abandon the whole project.
Well generally speaking if you chop them into
little pieces then you can confront them and
digest them.
And then you get stronger because you’re
doing all this digesting.
It’s like you’re eating the monster of
chaos.
And that’s a classic metaphor for developing
wisdom to ingest.
Piaget even uses that, right?
Assimilate.
It’s exactly the same idea as ingesting.
What you’re eating is information instead
of matter.
And the information restructures you and makes
you more informed.
And that puts you more in formation.
So you know you encounter the anomaly and
it’s a burst of contradictory potential,
and so that’s exactly how you respond to
it.
Your body’s going everywhere at once, because
God only knows what’s going to happen.
And then as you interact with it, it collapses.
You’re collapsing it.
That’s what happens when you take control
of the situation.
And then you reduce it to a single path where
everything is going properly.
And you might say well you’re bending it
to your own selfish will, but that’s not
right.
Because if you’re in… let’s say you’re
in an interview and there’s five or six
people in there, you can’t just bend the
damn thing to your will, because you have
to interact with those people.
And so if you don’t do that with… you
know, you could be a psychopath and manipulate,
but that’ll only work for a short period
of time, you’ll get caught, and then you’ll
have to move, because that’s what psychopaths
do, that’s how they keep being psychopaths.
They exhaust everyone’s trust and then they
have to move.
And then they go find some other people who
are trustworthy because they build up trust
capital with other people and then they betray
them.
But they have to keep moving.
So it’s an unstable solution.
So you go in there and you do it properly.
Well what are you doing exactly?
You know?
I would say that if you’re really, really
nailing that interview, you’re saying, well
here’s a future that we could all march
together into confidently and happily.
That’s what you’re saying.
And I’m the person to do that.
Now you might be saying that on a relatively
low scale.
Like, if I’m your assistant you’re never
going to have to worry about me.
Because I’m always going to be there.
And then maybe if you’re the CEO, you’re
going to say well, you know, this is the way
that all of us are going, and here’s why,
and this is what it’s going to look like.
And the better you are at that, the more that
potential will turn into… it multiplies,
that’s what happens.
If you’re good at dealing with it the potential
that’s accessible to you multiplies.
Which is really cool.
And also how you’d hope it would be.
Because you know, you’d hope that more potential
would manifest itself to people who are more
competent.
Well, if things work well that would be good.
So that’s the spirit and matter idea.
And so that’s represented in that dragon.
So let’s go back to it.
Now, okay, so you remember this character
here.
So what to do about that?
What to do about chaos?
Well one thing you might want to start by
doing is admitting that it exists.
So let’s say that you’re not a terror
management advocate.
Let’s say you’re an advocate of positive
illusions.
Does everyone know what those are?
Are you still taught about those in social
psychology, positive illusions?
Yes?
No.
How many people know about them?
Okay, where did you learn about them?
[Student: In your class, PSY230.]
In 230?
No one else has taught you about this?
Anybody else learn it anywhere else?
[Student: I learned it online.]
You learned it online.
Okay, well thank God for that.
Well, what happened was, the paper where positive
illusions were first touted, and that was
in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology,
it was the most cited… was it the most cited
paper ever in social psychology?
It’s up there.
And it’s an appalling paper!
Because it basically says… it says something
like this, if you scrape away all the nonsense:
things are so horrible that if you just looked
at them, you’ll be so depressed you’ll
want to die.
So you better not.
You better weave around yourself an illusion
that things are better than they are and that
you’re more powerful and wonderful than
you actually are.
And if you do that, but not too much, then
you’re going to be happier.
Well, you know, the errors in that are just
manifold.
First it’s like, well, who cares if you’re
happy, what the hell does that have to do
with anything?
You’d be happy stepping on ants.
[Laughter].
Well really!
It’s like what the hell stupid idea is that?
You’ve got positive emotion.
Cocaine will do that.
You know, bullies are pretty happy when they’re
pounding out someone like Milhouse.
So you know, happiness, what the hell’s
that?
It’s shallow.
It’s a dopey idea.
And then, well, how big should these lies
that you’re telling yourself be?
And the answer to that is just exactly the
size that will make you happy.
Well that’s not helpful, because if you’re
going to have a theory, let’s hear about
exactly how big they should be.
Well sometimes they should be this big and
other times they should be this big, but there’s
no real way of telling a priori.
Well so that’s not really very helpful either.
And then there’s another idea underneath
that that’s even worse, which is reality
is so awful that you can’t look at it.
Well that’s nasty man, because that means
(and that’s what the positive illusion stuff
meant, sort of like the terror management
theorists) if you got an unvarnished look
at reality, it would just destroy you.
Because you’re not strong enough to look
at reality in an unvarnished manner.
Well, you can imagine why people would believe
that.
You could think God yes, it’s pretty damn
awful.
But then you think, well wait a minute.
Is it really the case that everyone who’s
out there coping with the world is blind and
deluded?
Or maybe is it that the people who are not
coping with the world very well are blind
and deluded?
I mean, ask yourself that.
You’ve seen people in your life that you
admire, I presume, and certainly you’ve
seen people you don’t admire.
Well, so let’s take the ones you don’t
admire.
Well, how about blind and deluded, does that
partially describe them?
It would be blind, deluded, bitter, resentful,
and mean.
That sort of covers the territory.
And then the people you admire?
Well, they’re strong people, generally.
They can do things that are really, ridiculously
difficult, like have a baby, and raise it
without destroying it.
Or work in a palliative care ward or be a
nurse in a cancer ward for children.
I mean, there’s a lot of awful things.
I talked to this guy the other day.
I just met him sort of randomly.
And he had had a motorcycle accident.
And it was a bad one.
He rolled like 200 feet at 60 miles an hour
and he broke seven ribs and you know, had
a brain hemorrhage.
Like it really took it out of him.
He was a good athlete before that.
And so it probably aged him twenty years.
And he’s still recovering.
And he was telling me, he works for a power
company, and so he’s climbing up these power
poles, you know, because that’s part of
his job.
Well now he’s pretty screwed up.
He’s in his mid-fifties, he’s still climbing
up power poles.
And he was working with a guy who had Parkinson’s
disease.
And so the guy with the Parkinson’s disease
is at the top of the power pole and he’s
doing his job.
And he’s getting shaky, so they’re afraid
things are going to fall, and then this guy
comes up behind him to help him.
He’s only really got one arm that works.
It’s like, Jesus, that’s tough.
Those people are tough, man.
You know, because Parkinson’s?
That sucks.
And well, so does having half your arm more
or less destroyed by a motorcycle accident
and not staying at home hiding under the bed.
You know, they’re out there still making
sure the lights are on.
Well, that’s a pretty unvarnished confrontation
with reality as far as I’m concerned.
You know, so I could say… alright, so here’s
another story.
So, I’ve probably told you a little bit
about this before.
When the behaviourists first proposed that
you could use exposure to treat anxiety, the
psychoanalysts were all skeptical about that,
because they thought, well you’re just treating
the symptom.
They usually thought of a phobia as the manifestation,
the visible manifestation of something that
lurked more deeply underground.
And there’s real truth in that.
Like, whatever a mouse is to someone that’s
mouse-phobic isn’t what a mouse is to you.
The mouse is a bunch of other things, because
otherwise they wouldn’t be afraid of it.
And so all those…
you could say the mouse is an exemplar of
the category of all things that they’re
afraid of.
And that’s a good way of thinking what that
might mean symbolically.
And so I had one client who was afraid of
mice, and she thought one would run up her
leg.
And she was also afraid of being raped.
And those two things were…
there was a metaphorical union between them,
even though they’re obviously not exactly
the same.
So the psychoanalysts, they’re making their
point, you know.
But it turned out that… so the original
behavioural theory was you can’t be anxious
and calm at the same time.
So what you do first, if you’re going to
teach someone to not be afraid of a mouse,
is teach them how not to be afraid.
So you put them in a chair and you do a relaxation
exercise with them, and then you show them
a picture of a mouse.
And you say, just breathe, you know, calm
down.
And so they calm down.
And then sooner or later they can look at
the pictures of mice by themselves, and then
maybe you could throw a stuffed mouse at them,
and then maybe they could walk by a pet store
and look at a mouse, and so on and so forth,
till you get them holding rats.
And so, you know, that works.
But it works even if you don’t relax.
In fact it works just as well.
So the old behavioural idea that it was counter-conditioning
was wrong, just like the idea that the reason
that you were afraid of a rat was because
of conditioning.
It’s like, of course you’re afraid of
a rat, it’s a rat.
Just like you’re afraid of snakes, you know,
to a lesser or greater degree.
And people actually become more afraid of
snakes as they get older, interestingly enough.
Which is not what you really expect, right,
unless it was a biological function.
So anyways, all you have to do is show people
the thing they’re afraid of.
And what do they learn?
They don’t learn that the thing isn’t
frightening.
They learn that they’re tough.
And so one of the things… and that’s why
it generalises, which is… see the psychoanalysts
predicted that what would happen is, well,
you know, yeah, yeah, you’re not afraid
of a mouse anymore, but you’re twice as
afraid of being raped in your cabin when you’re
up there alone.
It’s like no, that isn’t what happens.
You’re not afraid of the mouse anymore and
you’re half as afraid of being alone up
in your cabin.
It generalises.
And so if you take someone who’s agoraphobic
and they’re in their mid-forties, and somewhat
dependent, and you treat them for agoraphobia,
then they’ll go home and give their husband
hell (because they’re usually women), and
tell them all the things that they’ve been
wanting to tell them for twenty years but
have been too afraid to because they thought
he might leave.
And then they were afraid that he’d leave
and they’d fall apart and all of that.
So they get…
you teach them that they don’t have to run
out of a subway and all of a sudden they get
more confrontational.
And the reason for that is because they get
more courageous.
And the reason for that is they go do something
difficult and they watch themselves and hey,
they could do it.
And so one of the things you might ask about
yourself is, how do you know what you have
to run away from?
You know, you might be so damn tough you just
can’t bloody well imagine it, and you’re
just sort of sheltered.
Now, look, you’re a lot less sheltered than
you were when you were three, I presume.
How many of you live on your own?
Okay, now, that was a transition, I presume.
How many of you were depressed and anxious
their first year of university?
Okay, how many of you weren’t?
Okay, so it’s about 50%.
Well that’s about right.
About a third of first-year UofT meet clinical
criteria for depression according to the Beck
Depression Inventory.
Well why?
Well it’s hard.
You know, you leave your family, you’re
kind of protected there, you go out, you have
to figure out all the things you have to do
to keep yourself alive and then you have to
go to university and they’re going to give
you an impossible amount of work that no one
could ever possibly master.
So it’s daunting.
And then you’re surrounded by people who
are smarter than the people you’re used
to being surrounded by.
So that means that you’re not as smart as
you thought you were.
And then you meet people now and then who
are way smarter than you and way harder-working
and way better-looking and all of those things.
So you know, it’s depressing.
But by the same token, how many of you feel
less armed to take on the world than you did
five years ago?
You’re not going to admit it, probably,
but I presume that that’s a very small number.
How many of you feel more prepared?
Okay, okay, so that’s pretty cool.
So what that means is that you went out there
and did a whole bunch of difficult things.
And some of those things…
you’ve been reading each other’s autobiographies
right?
How’s that going?
Has it been interesting?
Yeah, has it been worthwhile?
Anybody think it isn’t worthwhile?
I really want to know, you know, because it’s
kind of an experiment, in some sense, to see
how this is working.
What’s good about it?
[Student: That you can get to know a stranger
on the deepest level possible.]
So why do you like that?
[Student: Because it makes the class feel
more…]
Yeah you know I’m thinking about working
with a company in Edmonton that is setting
that up as a way of increasing trust among
people who work together in the same company.
They’re not really sharing their deepest
secrets, but what they will be doing is having
structured conversations where they find out
a little bit about each other.
You know, and it’s sort of… it seems like
to have a relationship with someone you have
to get to know their hierarchical structure,
right?
And it’s just like… like the tiniest things
while that person sits at the desk and types,
well, it’s a shallow relationship.
And if it’s a deep relationship you know
much more about the whole structure, right?
Which is I think why the metaphor of depth
works so well.
Okay, so you feel like it catalysed the classroom
a little bit more, is that right?
[Student: Yeah, and isn’t it like you fall
in love with someone…
this isn’t about falling in love, but you
fall in love with someone when they’re vulnerable?]
Yeah so that’s interesting too eh about
the whole vulnerability issue.
Yeah it’s like, if you’re forming a relationship
with someone what you do is you basically
mutually open up your shells you know.
Or basically you kind of go like this [opens
and closes hands].
And if it has to close permanently well then
you go.
Yeah well that’s another interesting thing
too because what it implies is that unless,
you know, you voluntarily expose your vulnerabilities
you’ll never find a partner, or they won’t
be a real partner because they don’t know
who the hell you are.
And then you’re weak because there’s only
one of you.
Yeah?
[Student: And the beauty in that is that it’s
completely anonymous too.]
Yeah and so why do you like that?
[Student: Because I can share my deepest secrets
but not feel like anyone will…]
You know there’s some evidence that people
like computer-guided psychotherapy.
For exactly that reason.
You can be completely honest with the computer
because it doesn’t care.
Not yet.
It will soon but, but it probably won’t
judge you any more harshly than you set it
to.
It’s like, love and affection today.
[Laughter].
Yeah, well that won’t be very far away.
Okay so what do other people have to say about
the autobiography?
Yeah?
[Student: I found it really interesting because
I never personally know so deeply what another
person thinks, because we don’t share that
much…
we talk about the beginning of childhood up
to this point, we never really have that conversation
with anyone else.]
So you like that too.
[Student: Yeah I like it a lot.]
Why?
What was good about it for you?
[Student: Usually as we move through stages
in our life we only interact with our age,
we never see them holistically.
But watching them grow, it’s kind of like,
very strange, because we don’t see people
that way.]
Right, well you’re seeing more of this eh?
[Points to Ouroboros image].
Because the person actually extends across
time, and you’re right, all you see is a
slice.
Well they’re not a slice, they’re a whole
damn thing, this thing that grows across time.
Okay, who else has something to say that’s
interesting?
[Laughter].
Haha, half the people don’t want to talk
now.
So, anybody else?
[Student: After doing that and writing so
many things about myself, I was actually talking
about the assignment with a couple of my friends,
and I really thought, I’d actually be okay
if the people who read my assignment identified
who I was and like, even engaged in conversation
with me.
And it really inspired me to be more honest
about sharing myself in my existing relationships.]
So why did you conclude that it would be okay
if someone identified you?
[Student: Because I felt a desire to be seen
more.
And it was kind of…
I felt more with myself when I was disclosing
more information about myself.
And so it made me want to be more with myself
in my existing relationships.]
Okay, that was a very good observation.
I’m going to say a couple of things about
that and you tell me if you think they’re
accurate.
Okay so the first thing is, it’s an act
of courage to, haha, expose yourself to someone…
no we’re not going to say that precisely.
It’s an act of courage to be truthful with
someone.
Because they’re actually interacting with
the actual you.
So there’s no façade.
So that’s one thing.
So you get more courageous.
But then the next thing might be…
I would say that you have a more sympathetic
relationship with yourself.
Because let’s say you have this stupid memory
about something dumb that you did when you
were 13.
And you’re still carrying that along.
It’s like, Jesus, you were 13, what the
hell do you expect?
13-year-olds are just dumb as sticks, they’re
going to do all sorts of stupid things.
Their brains are all addled from hormones
and they’re trapped in those little educational
prisons.
So they’re going to do stupid things.
But if you’re carrying that it’s like
it’s you that did that.
It’s not some stupid 13-year-old that you
once were.
And so then you can start to see yourself
in perspective, you know, as a 13-year-old
like other 13-year-olds.
No better, but perhaps no worse.
So you can get on your side, in some sense,
by walking through your story and seeing what
the causal elements are.
Does that seem reasonable?
Okay, okay, yeah, well so that’s a good
thing.
[Student: I think…
I really liked it, again, because you really
get to know other people and I really liked
that.
I think that it was also interesting that
other people not necessarily knew more about
you than you did, but they contemplated the
information that you gave them… like I know
that someone looked at something that I’d
written in a completely different light than
I did, and I thought that was so interesting.
Just like, the idea of kind of looking at
it a little bit more from the outside, and
getting a different perspective on it.]
Right, well that’s… what’s the famous
poem on the best gift we can possibly be given
is to see ourselves as others see us?
I think it’s Robbie Burns and I just mangled
the hell out of it.
But yeah, you do get that opportunity, and
it’s weird.
And this is something the positive illusion
people never think about either.
It’s that sometimes people think they’re
better than they are, like objectively, whatever
that means.
But lots of times the opposite is true, and
I think it’s often it’s true even more
often.
It’s like, people think they’re a lot
worse than they are.
No one’s as anxious as me or as concerned
about X or is as confused about this or as
socially awkward, or is not funny, or you
know, everybody’s got their paranoia about
this part of them that’s the worst that
anyone could possibly be in the entire world
and it’s almost never true.
Other people are a lot more like that than
you think.
And they’re running around trying to hide
it madly as well.
So that’s a good thing.
Well you know, you’re also allowing yourself…
in some sense you’re allowing yourself up
into the light.
You go through your life and you think, well
I can allow other people…